hey what's up guys mkbhd here and we're
back with episode one of our fastest mac
mini in the world project so give a
thumbs up if you like this series idea
and uh without any further ado let's go
ahead and get started with episode
number one now first of all some of you
guys may be asking well mkbhd why did
you pick the mac mini of all the mac to
choose that are out there right now why
the 2011 mac mini well first of all it's
the only mac that lets me use two of the
most vital things that i use all the
time on my other computers and that is
number one the three monitors that i
have i have three dell ultra sharp
24-inch 1920x1200 monitors i love the
high resolution i love the setup and i
don't plan on leaving that anytime soon
and second sata 3 and the mac pro is
actually out because it doesn't support
six gigabit per second set of three so
putting a blazing fast ssd in there is
not going to do it on the mac pro
because it just won't read it that fast
so a totally top of the line spec out
mac mini was the option that i had we're
going to take this to the max so this
video is going to be more an overview of
the series and an intro to what we're
going to do to this mac mini first of
all we'll be getting the fastest single
ssd solution that money can buy faster
even than the 256 gig ssd that apple
would ship if you bought it with the mac
mini it'll be about 540 extra to get
that but we're going to look for an
option that's even faster than an ssd
and uh near the same capacity and that's
going to give us instant you know
application opening that's going to give
us really fast boot times excellent
performance and that's all really what a
powerful desktop is all about we are
also going to be installing the most ram
that this mac mini can handle and uh
yeah you guessed it that's 16 gigs of
ram we're gonna try to find 16 gigs of
ddr3 ram for this project so the
combination of that blazing fast ssd and
tons of ram you might be able to edit
video and really make this thing work
for us we're going to top it all off
with a fresh install of mac os 10 10.7
lion so if you don't already know yeah
that's what this machine will come with
and uh we're definitely going to give
this a shot and see how far we can work
with it so to sum it all up this
overview huge fast ssd tons of ram fast
ram and does 10 10.7 lion so we can only
begin with the unboxing of the mac mini
itself we went with the of course
highest end available mac mini to start
with which would be the 2.7 gigahertz
intel core i7 model of course with the
thunderbolt port on the back and since
people like to watch apple unboxings i
might as well include the rest you know
you get the apple stickers you get the
literature you get the power cable and
what's nice is you actually get this dvi
to hdmi connector so you'll instantly be
able to set up a dvi display setting up
line for the first time was of course
pretty simple and of course you can see
here we finally got into our first uh
10.7 lion experience we'll start off
episode 2 where this episode left off
again if you like this video series idea
make sure to give it a thumbs up and uh
we'll see you in the next episode thanks
for watching guys
peace
[Music]
you